sticking with the International Women's
Day theme I'm delighted to say we're now
joined by Cherie Blair the founder of
the Cherie Blair foundation for women
thank you for being with us happy
International Women's Day
are you worried that it's all going to
be overshadowed by a coronavirus
absolutely not I think that I that
international Woman's Day is a very
special day in the calendar where we
remember the to extreme for women and
also the fact that they're still not
able to play their full role in society
you say they're about not being able to
play their full role in society and I
know that you've been doing a lot of
work on economic inequality that women
face
what exactly does that mean well I think
it it's very clear if you look at the
World Economic Forum Global Gender Gap
and they measure whether women and men
are having equal access to opportunity
this year the report showed that in
relation to economic opportunities
actually the situation for women had
deteriorated and so the gender burying
the gender gaps now going to take 257
years which is 55 years longer than the
year before
and the reason for that is a number of
things firstly women are often
concentrated in low pay low skilled
factory jobs that are creasing ly
becoming automated then on top of that
the new jobs that are being created a
stem job science technology and women
are not underrepresented in those fields
so they're missing out on the old types
of jobs and not gaining the new kind of
jobs and there's the perennial of course
women have the greater burden of the
caring responsibilities in the family
still and then finally it's about
attitudes to women the the cultural the
social and indeed in some places the
legal barriers to the perception of what
women can and cannot do what kind of
thing can make a difference to this what
what could be done to benefit women
economically well I think it's about
recognizing that women can do not the
idea that because you're or when there
are things you can't do it's interesting
of my foundation published some research
today about working the women we were
working with
and so many of them knew 3/4 of them
have experienced some kind of sexual
stereotyping particularly the idea that
women can't do business have you
experienced something that yourself in
your career well some however I tell you
what I did experience and that is the
experience of my mother and my
grandmother where for them the
opportunities were much less than I had
when I was first entering the market
into in the 70s but even then you know
you would go as a young lawyer and
they'd say oh we don't take women here
because women aren't really suitable to
be certainly barristers and advocates
all they'd say actually we do have a
woman so obviously we couldn't possibly
have more than one already ticked that
box so but you know for the women
entrepreneurs you find that apparently
they're told women don't do business or
women can't manage money or women are
not ambitious enough to make good
business people well when you think
around the world how women actually
mostly manage the finances the family
the idea that women don't do money is
ridiculous you were talking about
earlier about how things are getting
worse and when it comes to gender
equality does it feel like the world is
going backwards and why do you think
that is well I think it's it's
absolutely the case in economic
empowerment it's going backwards and
it's interesting the gap is narrowing in
education and health but then you look
actually where the power is Sophie
politics and economics in politics you
know there's less than three women for
every ten men in political life and in
the economic field it's like six women
to ten men so you can see that where the
power is it's still very difficult for
women to break through are you
disappointed then that it looks like
we're going to see a all-male slug out
again in the US presidential election
well you know in the end what's
important I think is that we see more
women role models and whether you've got
I mean obviously I was a huge supporter
I am a huge supporter of Hillary Clinton
I'd love to have seen her president of
America but the fact is she still
remains a role model and if we look
around the world women
speaking up women leaders in whatever
field they are more women in politics
all of these things are important
whether you get to the top job or not is
a combination I think of luck and talent
and how about the Labour leadership in
here I was going to ask would you like
to see a female leader well similarly
it's a combination of luck and talents
and the most important thing is that we
have seen that women can do the job that
women are prepared to put themselves
forward to the job and in the end the
contest will be who the membership think
the best person is to win is it always
about luck and tell them because some
women looking at this might think
actually you know what I'm not sure if
it is always luck in talent because
there's never been a female leader at
the labour party maybe something else is
coming into it as well you're talking
again I think about perceptions about
the same as that I was saying and women
can't be advocates or the same as our
business women fine and they say women
don't take business seriously I mean yes
there are societal assumptions about
what women can do what men can't do and
the more we see women breaking free of
those constraints the more we will see
other young women coming up behind them
saying she can do it I can do it and I
think that's my role models are so very
important usual remote of them I have a
number of role models when I was a young
lawyer starting out rose how broad the
first woman who was the first woman to
come a QC was from Liverpool like me and
in a mad sort of moment I thought well
if one girl from Liverpool can do it so
can i but then you know when I became a
QC in 95 I was still only number 74
so from 1949 when Rose was the first QC
to me in 1995 versus only another 73
women and in the first up until the
1970s only five and then and just
finally you of course performed one of
the roles or jobs I always think would
be one of the most difficult to to as
the kind of prime minister spouts and
you of course had a baby in number 10 as
well at Kari Simmons and Boris Johnson
expecting their first child what would
you give any advice to Kerry Simmons on
the madness of what that must be like I
don't think that very Perry needs any
advice to me she must do what what it
what is right for her but for everyone
expecting the first baby it's both
exciting and under and a real
Challenge and I wish you well and did
you you relieved to be out at the job
now or do you miss it a little bit it
was a great privilege to live in number
10 and to have that front-row seat on
politics but I do have more freedom now
to say what I think and to go after the
cause as I care in including of course
women's economic empowerment to make
sure that when a woman has her own money
she can make the choices which otherwise
are denied her because money talks in
this world and money gives you choices
so go for it okay thank you very much
Cherie Blair there on International
Women's Day thank you